hi I'm Chris Wilson from grinding Gear
games and I'm with Jonathan Rogers our
technical director today we'll be
showing you some of path of Exile
ascendency so this is the expansion
we've been working on since the release
of the awakening earlier this year The
Awakening came out in July and we're
expecting to release ascendancy in early
2016 so to tell you some about the
expansion the basic idea is that a few
hundred years ago in Wraeclast an
emperor called Azzaro
decided that he wanted to try a
non-standard way of finding a successor
to his throne rather than hiring an heir
and so he built a set of trials
throughout the world of great class that
people can compete in and if someone's
able to complete all six trials
successfully then they're able to gain
access to a dangerous labyrinth called
the Lord's labyrinth and of course if
someone's able to complete the labyrinth
without dying then they get to become
the Emperor and so ascendency is the
story of how you get to find these
trials in the world and then complete
them and hopefully gain access to the
labyrinth of yourself so at the moment
Jonathan's playing through one of the
existing areas in the game and is
looking for the first trial so upon
encountering it you find a door like
this to the trial of ascendency now each
of these six trials are special because
they introduce a new type of trap and as
you can see here we have these spinning
blade traps now these types of traps is
something we weren't able to do in path
of Exile before to be honest because i
netcode just wasn't up to it it was very
difficult with client/server
synchronization for us to run stuff like
this where your position matters exactly
but now that we have that sorted out
with the release of the awakening
earlier this year we're able to do these
complicated traps and so each of the six
trials has a puzzle that you have to
solve switching levers our flicking
switches and dodging the traps this
particular one is teaching you the
mechanics of how spinning blades work
and it's a gentle introduction one that
can be lethal but it means that later on
when you encounter spawning spinning
blade traps in the labyrinth you'll
understand how the mechanics work so
that you are able to get through some
much more difficult puzzles
so upon completing our given one of
these trials you find this plaque
tapping technical six of them in the
world gives you the ability to access
the labyrinth so now with this one
complete Jonathan's going to walk to a
different area and show you a completely
different type of trap so this one here
is inside the crematorium in acts three
and it demonstrates the rising lava trap
so as you can see on the screen at the
moment there's lava and you'll die if
you go down there so Jonathan's going to
wait until a lava subsides then explore
this area now the interesting thing to
note about this place is that they're
released fire skeletons and they ramune
to the larva effects they come out of
various monsters spawn us and once the
lava starts provides again used to get
very fast so he needs to run to safety
otherwise he'll die in a couple of
seconds now the puzzle behind this one
relatively simple because there's an
introductory trial is to find a way of
stopping all the skeletons from spawning
and timing it with a lava and we've
placed some just far enough away so that
by the time you deal with a spawner you
have only a few seconds to get back to
safety before the inevitable
incineration occurs
so throughout the world we have six of
these introductory areas and the goal is
that by the time the players completed
all six of them they understand the
broad mechanics of how things going to
work on the labyrinth speaking of which
it's time to show you the actual
labyrinth itself it's entering via
airlock of a labyrinth named after that
because it's a place where once you
enter you can't leave it's it's kind of
like a a localized hardcore mode
basically you get one shot of the
labyrinth before you're ejected from it
so this area here used to be very
fertile hundreds of years ago when it
was grown but now most of the irrigation
has failed and is covered and kind of
drive ruined plants so upon entering
this has locked it in so that this is
going to be a one-person run of the
labyrinth you can play with up to six
people if you have a party though of
course as people die they can't rejoin
so the labyrinth contains a new type of
level generation for path of Exile now
this is already a game with a lot of
random level generation in the labyrinth
the overall metal layer changes every
day so each day players encounter a
completely different order of levels
with different connections between them
so for example there might be a secret
passageway leading from level 1 to level
4 or maybe there's a different type of
trap prisms that particular day in a
various and various different areas and
we've done a lot of interesting stuff
with connecting up the areas preparing
keys and hidden switches and that kind
of stuff so that the playthrough of the
labyrinth varies a lot from day to day
this also means that throughout the day
players are able to discuss what the
day's layout is like and find better
ways to solve it now today for example
there's these two golden doors at least
of different areas and both of them say
that they need a golden key to open so
Jonathan's task now is to find where the
golden key is which is hopefully in a
nearby side area so that he can choose
which other's Forks to take now
initially he's not gonna know which fork
is better you have the place of
elaborate and twice to find out through
expecting players while trying to get
the best speedrun of the day to come up
with you know kind of a a group analysis
of the best way through the labyrinth
but of course players who discover
secrets can keep those secrets for
themselves if they want to so that they
can try to get a pass to run with other
people and we'll be tracking these
various runs on leaderboards so we can
basically see who's doing this on the
labyrinth that day so this area here
actually has a rising lava device that's
non-functional partly because a lot of
the a lot of the lab rentals and ruins
there were lots of broken traps all over
the place it's difficult to know which
ones work
don't but it can be very deadly when
they do work so this sub area of the
labyrinth is very much like the prison
and it contains a variety of different
traps here's the rising level one again
this one's fully functional I assure you
Jonathan oh it's not fully functional
yeah well I'm absolutely sure that is
fully functional level somewhere in here
so one of the characteristics behind
this area today is that there are towers
on these and these are ones that can
happen they can encumber your progress
as you move through it this is also home
to a lot of different types of traps
including the spike traps which is a
type that we haven't demonstrated so far
so great so this is an interesting thing
to talk about Jonathan's notice there's
a switch there and this is kind of
hidden it's certainly not mandatory that
you notice it so upon clicking the
switch you'll see that a wall opens up
and this is essentially a secret room
inside here this is a difficult fight
and there's also an object that's
labeled as a mysterious dark shrine now
the top of Excel players will know
exactly what this means but for the
uninitiated it's something which is
going to cause a powerful random effects
subtly different from the way we did
diet trends elsewhere this one adds
effect from the certain pool and this
particular one says feel the corruption
in your veins and now when Jonathan
loads up the map to see what mods now
fix the area you can see that monsters
now poison him when they hit but in
return the labyrinth now drops more
items with higher rarity so by
encountering these different shrines
usually hidden behind secrets you can
increase the difficulty of the labyrinth
and also increases rewards so Jonathan's
running across the spikes here they
trigger behind him and there are lots of
different criteria the house spikes work
some of them are on patterns some of
them wait until you get near them before
they trigger
that's a closed cooler right so at the
end of this particular crab gauntlet
there's a chest that has a golden key
inside it which enables the first of
today's puzzles to be solved so this
allows him to select from the two doors
in the previous area now the labyrinth
is generally made up of three broad
sections each one has several of these
puzzles trap gauntlets various side
areas super rooms and so on before you
get to a fighter boss at the end of it
and the three areas select from for many
different tile sets
now while this tile set here is a
variation of one that's used in the game
at the moment there are some tile sets
that are completely new internally known
as the elegant house and the dry garden
and so on they're ones that you'll get
to see in the travels here now it
sometimes pays to make a map of the
labyrinth that was a side area it's
important to know where you're going
because there is a lot of complexity and
otherwise it wouldn't be a labyrinth I
guess so that entity that you see on the
right there is a blade sentry a flying
variation there are two types of these
people finder labyrinth
they generally follow fixed paths this
particular one can fly over castles and
is very bad idea to get close to those
so I'm brother golden hey Jonathan's
able to go and pick which of the two
doors he later goes
so which will it be the right hand one
with the mostess behind it alright so
these are going to lead to different
areas and of course because the layout
changes every day I have no idea which
what is behind each of these two areas
you'll notice some broken spike cuts
there and other fake
great so this is a variation of the
Crypt and it's the area immediately
after that particular golden door of
course the other one would lead to a
different area this one has its own
distinctive types of traps emotion
right so the next mechanic we'd like to
talk about rather than doing a full
labyrinth playthrough is to demonstrate
how the boss fights work now you get to
fight Emperor's ro himself and the
interesting thing here is that you're
fighting multiple times throughout the
labyrinth but the effects of one battle
will affect the other ones so upon
fighting them the first time the fight
is simpler than the other one says less
stuff going on but the way that you deal
with it dictates a lot how the other
ones work so Emperor's ro has a spirit
of Buffum which is the goddess that he
was worshipping before he was inch over
to this labyrinth and the Spirit will do
area-denial and basically cast things
while he's got his own agenda now this
particular variation of the fight has
these three statues as you can see
Jonathan's running around and tagging
them now these three statues each embody
different elements so for example
there's a lightning one up there that
he's tagging there's a fire one up here
and a cold one down there and as the
statue is active as arrow gains
additional power able to hurt you with
those elements so tagging the statutes
disables them and that's important to
make the fight manageable otherwise it's
pretty deadly
so once you've tagged them you want to
run in and do some damage and
unfortunately of course the other
statues will activate while you're doing
so so you have to carefully balance
where he is in regard to them the whole
time he's summoning skeletons and the
goddess is trying to deny areas of the
ground by throwing projectiles down
now the mechanic here and there are many
different things where the statute is
just one of the many mechanics in a boss
page but this is the one that was
randomly picked today at the end of the
fight whatever century's arsenal actor
they're going to carry on to the next
one permanently so it's very important
to stay on top of the statutes because
if Jonathan gets Cesaro down too
critical healthier while there are
statues still alive then he'll have to
face those in the next fight plus
whatever mechanic sera now because there
are three phases to this you only have
to get his are up to a certain amount of
damage of what he'll retreat
approximately a third of his life so
here is arrows leaving and it's worth
noting these taking some of the statues
with it yep they're evokes it's not
finished yet the elevator works
perfectly on our testing version at home
I promise sorry he's who's taking a
statue with him after the three and
that's gonna be present in the next
fight now so upon finishing that section
there's now another large portion of the
labyrinth available we weren't spoiled
to a match of that that is full of traps
and Gordon us as well
upon encountering as our the second time
in area B 5 I just not something the
players need to worry about you'll
notice that he has one of these he has
one of these statutes permanently action
so that means he's getting like knee
damage and there's just nothing you can
do about it because Jonathan wasn't on
top of dealing with that statue on the
previous time so the mechanic here is
there are various areas on the ground
the deactivates and you want to stand
within them in order to be able to
damage him this is a completely
different way for the fight to operate
compared to before
in addition the fighters harder the you
know as our gains more abilities now we
have quite an interesting set of
different mechanics that can spawn on
the Asura fight like the rest of the
labyrinth is meant to be random each day
and we're trying very hard to keep that
set full of different things so the
players are always encountering new
variations and the goal here is that you
know on today's labyrinth run you'll see
some beautiful crab you haven't
necessarily seen the previous day and so
there's several weeks of dramatically
different labyrinth experiences for you
to have now as we'll discuss once the
boss fight has been completed there are
some pretty awesome rewards that you get
for completing labyrinths and these
rewards encourage you to not only play
through the labyrinth on each difficulty
on your character to get valuable
bonuses but also to replay the labyrinth
as much as you can because they allow
you to change your items in an
interesting way and this is one of those
systems that set up so the experienced
players will look at it and say you know
what I'm going to play a bunch of the
level
when designing the characters for the
demo here we purposefully fetch them so
that a civility of the challenging fight
others are great
so he's retreating and the fact that
there are still some circles active I
believe will power up the next fight so
this is now the third face of the
labyrinth which will skip over the traps
and as you can see it's a completely
different tile set this is a dry garden
one this one is home to some interesting
things I believe that the spinning
blades in trees it's got the shooters
right so yeah there's a lot of dart
shooters and the in the lab and the dry
garden which I believe we haven't shown
yet so this is the third phase of the
Nazario phase now it's important that we
have to show all three phases here
because otherwise you can't get the
rewards which is something he works out
so as as we continue with the
development the expansion of course will
continue and more variations of the
fight these are the few prototypes that
we have working at a moment now you'll
notice that the that the goddess on top
is causing versions of it up here on the
grounds of various places on this
creates area now so a mechanic here is
that lieutenant's get introduced
throughout the fight bizarro has three
lieutenants that are immortalized on the
labyrinth with him and they add to the
fight and it's very important for you to
deal with these as they appear because
if you let all three ounces are is going
to become extremely dangerous
yep so he's out of flasks here so he has
to go and kill some skeletons to get
last chat respect
so this is this is where it starts to
get really difficult now normally in a
regular playthrough if Jonathan would
have died here that's those labyrinth
attempt for the Sisko completely over
you know you have to start from the
beginning at each time in this
particular version and due to the fact
that we expect to die in our demo we've
set it up so we can start again from the
beginning of the spite of it happens so
thankfully it's not all over in that
case it looks like he's handling it okay
here he's got one of the lieutenant's
down out of a three total now depending
on what's picked for a given day the
earlier mechanics that you've
successfully or failed to bypass may
effectively turn some different ways in
this particular case as our as lightning
damages that is very dangerous for him
to hit you but also extremely dangerous
and their lieutenants around you
distracting you during the process great
so fun killing is ro you get some item
drops and then you're able to move
through to the ascendency chamber where
you get to see the rewards now this is
the reason why people are completing the
labyrinth there are basically two things
here so the first one is a system they
were adding in this expansion and this
is the big deal so this is a concept of
ascendancy classes each of the character
classes a path of Exile can now
specialize in one of three subclasses so
the duelists at Jonathan's plan can now
become a Slayer gladiator or champion
and this is something we've never had in
path of Exile before there were seven
classes and a massive skill tree but now
we have the ability to further
specialize into one of 19 new subclasses
which enables you have 26 distinct types
of character in the game and so these
basically take the take your given class
in three different archetypal directions
the Slayer is dramatic leader from the
gladiator which is dramatically
different from the champion for example
the champion has nodes like
inspirational which mean that you and
your allies have additional damage a
movement speed and this is great for
duelists who want to run a bunch of
auras or want to specialize and things
like fortify here this permanently gives
you this buff that was previously a
conditional thing that you could only
get sometimes
so he's selecting the gladiator and this
has a bunch of modes that we can show
you here an example is say gratuitous
violence and this one here increases
your chance of causing bleeding on
enemies which is something that's
normally tricky to do and then causes
them to explode if they die while
they're bleeding so you can kind of
chain a bunch of enemies dying together
so joint allocate
two points in the gratuitous violence
great so you get two points for each
time you complete the labyrinth and a
new difficulty level so that means that
at this point in the game in Normal
difficulty at around level 35 or so
you've got your two points
then in crawl you get two more and a
merciless two more so you're able to you
aren't able to allocate your entire
ascendancy tree if you're able to get a
good portion of it and many of the nodes
but you still have to choose not only
what a sinner c-class to specialize in
but also what to do within that class so
the other reward that you get is
ascendency crafting this allows you to
push into sin and see model on item now
in Normal difficulty you can put on
models and gloves
so here Jonathan's adding one to his
gloves and it gives him word of blades
now I'll correct me if I'm wrong but I
believe this one causes blades to appear
as you kill enemies and it's got a cool
down on it
so Jonathan is now going to show some
combat both with the gratuitous violence
key stone that he selected with his
ascendency specialization but also the
word of blade skill so here at the dart
shooters that I referred to before and
the dray garden with the forces full of
the barrows our players will understand
what joy that brings and so because he
asked retort is violence it means that
there's a 10% chance of horses bleeding
on enemies I'll explode when they die
now this is relevant with a skill like
cyclone that he's using because cyclone
hits really really frequently and that
means where the chance of causing
bleeding I haven't quite a lot and if
they're a group of enemies close
together
you're able to chain the explosions if
you get that enemies bleeding watch your
health yep so the dart shoot is not only
I do quite a lot of damage but they also
slow you down further increasing your
vulnerabilities of traps and that means
there are some interesting hybrid trap
bullets in the labyrinth that combined
archers or other things that you're slow
when you really don't want to be because
of something horrible going on evolving
lava or spikes or blade sentries
right so one thing to note about the
scripture is violence specialization
here is that you have the ability to you
have the ability to purposefully set
someone to a bleeding state by using a
skill like puncture if you puncture them
then they will be guaranteed to explode
when they die so do you want to try out
the the word of Blades skill yep so yes
the Dajjal is podiatry there's now he's
had a lot of practice of us I'm terrible
myself which is why he's playing and I'm
just narrating so as you see once you
get hit the head start to pile up as you
gradually get machine guns on the corner
yeah so he's he's struggling yeah so
this pressure place that you can stand
on that will cause additional things to
trigger and we've tried very hard to
hide stuff like that all over the place
so you know the problems just keep
piling up as you're playing through this
if you're unprepared so once he gets
through here I've got to fight some
monsters to demonstrate the word of
blades skill so the idea with the
ascenders and mods on the gloves is that
you get a random one you don't want a
random one you want one of the ones
that's good for your character bill and
so it pays to do the lab runs
repetitively to try to get the mod that
you're looking for now in higher
difficulties there's a wider range of
different mods available and they can
draw more items great so is equipping
where the plates now sorting as Jim
great so now this means that's the the
green blades will fly between the
enemies making it a ton easier to kill
groups of monsters now there's a small
cool down on this what only triggers
sometimes but it basically adds a power
more damage and makes the fights a lot
easier so there's going to be no reason
at all don't want on the people sending
rods on they love and the ones have
higher difficulties they're not quite as
visual as these ones but they certainly
have some very impactful effects that
players will enjoy increasing the damage
and various other properties of specific
skills